Юрій Мазур - український лікар, який працює у Німеччині.
Медичну освіту він отримав у Львівському медуніверситеті у 2016 році.
Після цього фахівець із судинної патології проходив трирічну інтернатуру, також в Україні.
А своє перше офіційне робоче місце 27-річний Юрій отримав у… Клоппенбургу, що на півночі Німеччини.
Я, власне, родом з лікарської сім'ї. Мій тато - акушер-гінеколог.
Мама - дитячий кардіоревматолог. А брат - також акушер-гінеколог.
Якось так склалося, що з третього курсу навчання в медуніверситеті
почав їздити на різні практики і стажування в клініки за кордоном.
Польща, Німеччина, Австрія.
У німецькому місті з населенням 170 тисяч українець став почуватися комфортно,
коли покращив знання мови. Але спочатку, зізнається, було важко,
навіть попри рівень B2, з яким сюди приїхав.
Перше важливе, коли сюди потрапляєш - знання мови. Коли ти знаєш мову,
ти себе вільно почуваєш. Коли ти працюєш в іншій країні, тобі треба звикати до мови,
до ментальності. І коли приходить стрес і більше навантаження для тебе,
коли з'являються нові пацієнти, приходиш з операційного залу,
а ще інші пацієнти по відділенню потребують твоєї допомоги,
після того якісь нові госпіталізації з'являються. Більш інтенсивно тут життя проходить.
Тиждень проходить за тижнем. І так ми не помічаємо, як скоро час пролітає.
Робочий контракт лікаря-асистента Юрій Мазур підписав у грудні 2019-го.
А вже у березні Німеччину охопила пандемія коронавірусу, яка стала викликом
для українського лікаря та усіх його колег, багато з яких перехворіли.
Медична система Німеччини гідно витримала удар, на відміну від, наприклад, італійської.
Те, за що хвалили в найгірші часи кризи Німеччину, допомогло адаптуватися і Юрію.
До чогось нового важко адаптуватися. Я б не сказав, що було досить легко.
Але дуже складно теж не було. Тому що Німеччині притаманний порядок.
Кожного ранку робочий день починається о 7:30.
Ми зустрічаємось на так зване Rundenbesprechung. Так зустрічаються всі колеги
нашого судинного центру: радіологи, судинні хірурги, ангіологи.
І разом ми обговорюємо план на день та особливості лікування наших пацієнтів.
Зарплата лікаря-початківця в Німеччині - від чотирьох тисяч євро на місяць брутто.
В Україні Юрій отримував би у кращому разі 300 євро. Окрім гідної заоплати,
у ФРН молодого фахівця приваблює ще й більш зрозумілий шлях для кар’єри
та безкрайні освітні можливості.
Для прикладу - наступного тижня я їду в Берліні на курси. За ці курси я заплатив 600 євро.
Цю суму мені поверне клініка. Це кошти, які потрібно вкладати в своє навчання.
Але ці кошти потрібно потім заробити і потім знову вкладати.
Якщо в тебе нічого не залишається, якщо лікар приходить у супермаркет
і починає шукати продукти, які є за знижкою, коли починає економити,
тоді він втрачає свої сили, які мав би використати на свій розвиток.
Він втрачає свій час, коли мав би сісти ввечері за книжку щось почитати,
подивитись цікаві операції онлайн, онлайн-семінари відвідати.
А він мусить дбати про свою буденність.
Юрій Мазур - один із близько двох тисяч українських лікарів у Німеччині.
Принаймні такі дані наводить Федеральна лікарська палата станом на кінець 2020 року.
Щороку сюди на роботу приїздять від 100 до 200 нових фахівців з України.
Не кажучи вже про інший медперсонал. Шеф Юрія - уродженець Польщі - каже,
що українці - на гарному рахунку в Німеччині.
Я приїхав 32 роки тому з Польщі. Відтоді я мешкаю в Німеччині. З усією родиною.
У мене, власне, дуже добрий досвід з колегами зі Східної Європи.
У більшості немає проблем або вони незначні. Вони мають добру освіту.
Звичайно, їм потрібно скласти іспит, як це передбачено приписами.
І пан Мазур пару днів тому склав цей іспит. З першого разу, без жодних проблем.
Ми дуже задоволені ним. Він - визнаний лікар.
Не минуло і двох років після приїзду, як Юрій Мазур склав іспит і захистив фах лікаря в Німеччині.
Тепер він має дозвіл працювати не лише у Клоппенбургу, а у будь-якій лікарні Євросоюзу.
І у цьому, на думку Юрія, одна з ключових переваг Німеччини
для високоосвіченого медика, порівняно з Україною.
В плані академічної мобільності Німеччина та країни Шенгенської зони більш вільні, ніж в Україні.
Український молодий лікар, який отримав омріяне місце в клініці,
місце лікаря-ординатора в хірургії чи-то відділенні травматології,
чи-то кардіології, дуже хвилюється за своє місце. Він хвилюється,
щоб його раптом не звільнили. Виконує свої обов'язки і лиш би
все в мене було добре і спокійно. А, власне, лікарі в Європі більш вільні.
Ми можемо не хвилюватися за своє місце, бо в будь-який момент можемо
написати резюме в іншу клініку і ти можеш в іншій клініці теж себе проявити.
Працювати можна і на себе. Зарплати лікарів у Німеччині не просто високі,
а удвічі вищі середніх. Ще краще за медиків у лікарнях заробляють приватні лікарі.
Терапевт Роман Корвач зі Львівщини після п'яти років роботи
у лікарні святого Йозефа у Клоппенбурзі звільнився, аби заснувати
власну лікарську практику сімейної медицини.
Ми вирішили в сімейному колі йти далі в амбулантну медицину.
Я по спеціальності терапевт. Внутрішні хвороби. Інтерніст-терапевт
може стати сімейним лікарем. Тим я зараз і займаюсь.
За даними дослідження Центру Разумкова, у 2020 році Україну
залишили 66 тисяч лікарів та медпрацівників. Ексміністр Максим Степанов заявив,
що аби знизити відтік медиків за кордон, зарплата у 2021 році
має бути не менше 25 тисяч гривень.
Вже після відставки Степанова президент Володимир Зеленський своїм указом
розпорядився встановити з 2022 року мінімальну зарплату лікаря у 20 тисяч гривень.
Юрій Мазур сумнівається, що це може стримати масовий виїзд фахівців з України.
Водночас він підкреслює, що багато лікарів залишалися б,
якби реформи у медицині дійсно втілювалися в життя.
Дискусії ми над цим продовжуємо вже декілька років. Приходять одні міністри.
Вони йдуть - приходять нові міністри. В них якісь свої нові ідеї.
Але на жаль, досі за стільки років не було ідеального рішення,
яке б нам допомогло вийти з цієї важкої ситуації.
Я не маю на увазі, що лише проблеми є в Україні. Проблем є багато теж і в Німеччині, і в Австрії, і в Польщі.
Потрібно, щоб усі були зацікавлені ці проблеми вирішувати.
Є люди, які створили свою зону комфорту і не хочуть розвиватися.
І вони стримують розвиток інших. Ось це я вважаю проблемою в Україні.
На думку українського фахівця, який з власного досвіду може порівнювати
медичні системи України, Австрії, Польщі та Німеччини, для вирішення проблем
української медицини у цьому повинні бути зацікавлені всі причетні.
І лікарі, і пацієнти повинні бути готовими до змін і працювати над ними разом.